[Music]  what have I got myself into  it's like hugely cultural and the foods  like amazing that's one of the best  things I've ever tasted  you're my tour guide Cheers  this is the dream what is anything I  never know I just go for it  well that's oil I like countries that  there's no cohesive American perception  of what is there what do you think I  love LA because if still a sense  discovery I'm always a student of a  culture of the craft I'm excited to try  new things I was gonna say the best part  of traveling and speeding but I think  that's wrong it's the conversations that  you have the people that you meet it's  really perfect you come out here and you  feel more special than you do anywhere  else in the world  and I have an affinity for places that  have a complex history whoa right I've  never seen something like this  oh that's what  [Music]  you  you